hey everybody its charlie we got all
kinds of Justice League Aquaman stuff
happening I also included some arrow at
the end of this there's a new round of
the flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so just because so
much stuff happened I'm going to start
with Aquaman then I'll talk about the
Aero stuff so Jason Momoa was talking a
lot about where his character is how he
fits into the Justice League but they
just started shooting the Aquaman movie
this week so the way he was talking
about his character is he says the guy
was never really accepted on land he was
never really accepted in Atlantis he's a
half-breed but he's the best of both
worlds he just doesn't know how to
handle his power so it's kind of a
coming-of-age from a young man to a man
or a man to a king he's lost a lot of
things and he's got a cope he's an
outsider and then they said that that
would continue through to justice like
he'd be this big outsider character as
you've seen during the Justice League
trailers he definitely seems like a good
person initially he's not like an
[ __ ] or anything because he saves
that dude that looks like he crashed his
boat out in the ocean this drinks on him
before he goes on this way and bumps
into Batman you can tell just based on
that trailer after Batman explains the
threat of what's going on they all in
their armor fighting the parademons he
starts to loosen up a little bit and
it's the same for Batman like they're
all very antisocial people until later
in the movie when they come together
muster courage and here you can talk to
fish
it's good to see you playing well with
others again just like a bat I dig it
may be temporary
but if you happen to live in Queensland
Australia they're shooting a ton of the
movie there they're also filming in
Newfoundland Sicily and Tunisia so a
couple of those locations like Sicily
for example you can assume that they're
probably going for the architecture so
that it can double for some Atlanta
scene because you look at this new 52
run you see it has a lot of Greek Roman
aspects to it but you guys can let me
know if you've been reading the Aquaman
comic books recently what you think
about the title what you want them to
include from his character just because
it takes so long to get movies going it
takes a long time to write scripts most
of this is taking from new 52 the more
recent stuff rebirth was kind of in the
works when they were working on this
script so I'm not expecting to see a
whole bunch of rebirth in here and even
Justice League the rebirth team in
Justice League is completely different
it's more like Suicide Squad because you
have killer frost you have Lobo so if
you're looking for Aquaman comics to
read for the Aquaman movie I would
recommend you start with the seven seas
storyline which is basically geoff johns
new 52 run he definitely pushed up
Aquaman even though Peter David classic
Aquaman is pretty cool too I'm not
expecting him to get his hand chopped
off or anything like that anytime soon
Jason Momoa would probably be down to do
that but if they haven't done something
like that in seven seasons of Walking
Dead to Rick Grimes character and
they're probably never going to do it to
Aquaman but we do have Black Manta the
actor who plays him is just getting all
jazzed up I always love it when the
actors that are relatively new to make
comic book films just go out and start
binging the comic book for the movie
that they're in so side note if you are
a big Black Manta fan and it's been a
while since you've seen anything with
him in it he is huge
during Young Justice because of
aqualad's character so rewatch a lot of
the Netflix Young Justice stuff because
it's awesome and they're actually coming
back during Young Justice season 3 but
we can do a separate video about that
later but if you're not jazzed up about
Aquaman already just watch amber her
here being adorable
push
which I believe all your requests for
more Justice League bonus videos in the
comments below there was that Lego set
that had Steppenwolf in it but we kind
of already know what Steppenwolf looks
like he's going to be freaking huge he's
going to wreck the Justice League so
it's not exactly news they may or may
not work him into one of the final
trailers like they barely put Ares in
The Wonder Woman trailers I'm expecting
the same thing for Justice League based
on previous experience with Batman V
Superman doomsday stuff last year
everybody was so bummed out after they
revealed doomsday even though we all
probably knew he was going to be in the
movie
the really big take away I think is when
he says we've never really seen anything
from this guy before so it's fun to have
a level playing field you talking about
with the audience like with us the
people that are going to see the movie
there aren't like for Aquaman's before
me I get to set the tone for it so I
think that's why Aquaman has the chance
to surprise everyone it's the least
pressure that they have like obviously
there's a lot of pressure because it's
going to be a hundred fifty million
dollar movie but it doesn't bring nearly
the baggage of a character like Batman
so during the Batman movie everyone will
have crazy expectations because of how
good the Dark Knight was how much of a
relationship they have with the
character so people like Aquaman but he
is nowhere near as popular as Batman so
they are having all the fun right now
and based on his description Aquaman
will be the most powerful character in
the Justice League after Superman with
his Trident underwater he could go
toe-to-toe with Superman easily even
though the Justice League version of
Superman is way more Opie than
comic-book Superman but depending on
which version of the Trident he's using
in the movie it can actually generate
its own water and it looks like he uses
it a couple times during the trailer but
we haven't seen everything it can do yet
so you'll probably see more from each of
the characters that met
time we get Justice League footage but
moving on to arrow stuff so a lot of
people were taken aback because they did
a bottle episode if you're not familiar
with that that's where you do an episode
that's largely self-contained that
doesn't have a lot of sets so that you
can save money for a later episode where
you overspend because there's usually
like a budget for each episode of TV
that you film so the more you spend on
one episode the less you can spend on
another so arrow did a bottle episode
with felicity and Oliver stuck in the
bunker because you know we've all talked
about the finale Heather going back to
Lian Yu they're bringing back every
awesome arrow character that you've ever
heard of that's probably why they did
this bottle episode so it is Star Wars
day there were a couple solid Star Wars
references looks like the Death Star
interrogation joy they did a great job
with the suspense militias move on to
the trailer for the next episode episode
21 because that's when we get crazy
Prometheus stuff every time I take a
step forward it feels like the past is
holding me back where are we on finding
Jason or nowhere I'm a real - absence or
go chase
they're here
we mine
so we're finally back to crazytown on
arrow but at the end of last week's
episode he found all of her son who's
now calling himself Matthew instead of
William fees are sort of hiding out
witness protection style he's nowhere in
this trailer so that's a big part of the
episode but they're mostly hyping up
Cody Rhodes coming back working with
Prometheus so there's only a couple
episodes left and you kind of see what's
going on here Prometheus is starting to
work with Oliver's greatest enemies that
are still around so there's more black
siren on the way he's going to start
working with her Merlin's coming back
into play from legends of tomorrow so if
you're not cut up on that show we can
talk about it during that episode but
Merlin on arrow has had his mind reset
so he's not going to remember anything
from legends of tomorrow which sounds
weird doll explain why they did that
when I post that episode video then of
course we have big finale Deathstroke
stuff and then you have all the stuff
going on in the flash too so I'm not
expecting a whole lot of crossover
between the shows in the last couple of
episodes but there might be some brief
moments just because the things that
each team is experiencing are so
different and so dire things are so
crazy for team flash right now they're
so crazy for Oliver so there's not a lot
of time for them to hang out with team
flash but because it's Star Wars days
I'm posting this video my next video
will be last Jedi so that should be up
in a couple hours be sure to go see
guardians of the galaxy if you haven't
seen it already I'll be posting a couple
of those videos in the next couple days
too congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner the white wolf please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for that next
video you can click here for my
guardians of the galaxy review and you
can click here for a brand new flash
footage thank you so much for watching
with five-five I'll see you guys tonight